when olympic gold medalist tom daley was
spotted crocheting at the tokyo games
this summer the world went crochet crazy
and lucky for us
here on our show we've been crochet
crazy that's right because it all
started with our next guest
crochet prodigy jonah larson has been a
friend of this show and mine since the
very beginning do you see that that's he
and i
during the pilot i just loved and
respected him so much and we became very
close and he first captured our hearts
with his amazing crochet videos but more
importantly
it's who jonah is
that really inspires me here's his story
so you understand too
jonah larson oh he is such an amazing
soul and he's the crocheting phenom
taking the needlepoint world by storm
and i met and we became fast friends
look remember back when we could hug
jonah's wise beyond his years he
authored his first book at 11 and he
helped create a new library in the
ethiopian village he was born in
thank you
we love you he is an inspiration to me
and i think we have so much to learn
from him he's so knowledgeable too and
he has great taste in movies and tv he's
so well read
the award-winning life-affirming
cross-stitching jonah larson
[Music]
for the first time in two years i get to
see him in person please welcome my dear
friend jonah larson
[Applause]
oh my gosh
this has been such a long journey
it is and before we get started i have
to start this how i always start with
hello crochet friends
what did you think
about the crochet world hitting the
olympics and like olympics ex-crochet
it was so cool to see tom daley the gold
medal winning diver crocheting because
it really brings crochet to a whole new
generation of younger folks and it shows
that it's for everyone not just a
grammar hobby it's for men and everyone
else included and i think maybe crochet
might even be an olympic sport one day
because of the hand dexterity needed
no kidding
well of course um you know i was
watching tom daley the whole time
thinking of you and um he knew that you
were going to be on the show today so he
has a message for you oh wow
hi jonah it's tom daley here olympic
diver but also fellow stitching
enthusiasts and i just wanted to say how
awesome i think you are one your designs
are amazing but secondly
you're just incredible and you're so
fast and i'm able to talk at the same
time as doing all of those stitches and
the way that you speak so eloquently
about it and how much happiness and joy
you bring to so many people one day i
hope i'm gonna be able to meet you and
we can have a little sit down and we can
have a stitch i can knit crochet we
could all have a little lovely time but
in the meantime keep doing what you're
doing i think you're awesome
crochet away friends
you know i thought it was cool when i
won 20 blue ribbons at my local state
fair and i'm rethinking that
that's pretty baller that tom daley is
saying that is super cool your
theme your term crochet away
yeah that was pretty cool i wasn't
expecting that okay so a big part of who
you are um you know is that you give
back to meaningful causes and recently
you completed a big project in ethiopia
and can you tell us about it i'll start
with a little origin story and backstory
so when i was six months old i was
adopted from a very rural area in
ethiopia that didn't have a library
science lab or a school altogether
really
and i've been working with thousands of
people
and you too because you helped me built
and i was able to build a library that
services over 2000 students it has 3 000
books
and i've also been able to give them a
science lab and now they've received an
award called the federal medallion for
academic excellence from the ethiopian
government so such a big champion
[Applause]
i mean
jonah you were adopted in ethiopia and
like what is it that makes you be the
kind of person that says i want to give
back to that community
well i have to give the credit to my mom
over there in the mint shirt because
she's the one there she is hi
how are you
and um i heard that you also still have
some big plans for the school as well
the school's received an award for
academic excellence but it's still not
up to hygiene standards yet and they
have a outhouse that doesn't meet their
needs and it's not good for those
children so right now i'm working on
building latrines for them so that um
females and they can have their privacy
so they can attend school all the time
and get a good education and you have a
gofundme and you have a gofundme website
jonahans.com and i've already raised
1500 for this part of the project but i
still have 5 500 to go okay well thank
you for bringing the awareness and
attention to everything that you do
jonah now back to crocheting we have a
few audience members here and i'm so
excited to introduce a new segment we're
calling crochet and a
[Music]
all righty here we're gonna go to our
first question it's to carmen let's see
carmen
there you are carmen
welcome to the show thank you
hi jonah my question is i'm trying to
get my daughter into crocheting to get
excited to crochet with me
is there a go-to project that you can
tell us about that for beginners the
project i would recommend is
it's actually a hat pattern that i made
it's a pattern from yarnspirations.com
where you can find it'll be up on
drewberrymore's website
and it uses
it uses a chunkier yarn so that way you
can use a bigger hook and it goes faster
and it's also easier to start for a
beginner so i recommend using that hat
to start with your daughter
thank you so much
thank you so much all right
next we're going to natalie
hi jonah hello um so i love to crochet
but i really want to get my husband more
involved so how can we get more men
involved in crochet just in general
you know the best way to answer that is
who just sent the video over tom daley
so that just shows you that it's for
everyone and
so that's my take on it thank you
all right
we have one last question from kelly
please stand up oh hi kelly how are you
oh hi
hey jonah hello my question is how do
you combine your love for crocheting
with your love for giving back to others
the way i do that is by using my crochet
to raise money for causes for example i
sometimes make items and then auction
off a blanket and however much money it
raises i give it to my charities and
then other times i do events with
organizations like just recently i did
one with an organization called hats and
mittens which gives hats and mitten sets
the kids in need in minneapolis so
there's so many different things you can
do to combine your love with crafting
and being a fiber artist with giving
back and i make sure i just do that
every single time i stitch excellent
okay thank you guys so much for your
thoughtful question
um
[Music]
that is um just so wonderful okay now
jonah before we go i just want to say
that um our show wants to give you the
remaining 5 500 for your gofundme page
which will complete
[Applause]
thank you so much
that's going to help a lot of kids in
ethiopia so they let you know that
all right thank you jonas so much
[Music]
you